Candlestick patterns are one of the most
important Concepts when it comes to
trading profitably yet you'd be
surprised that most Traders still use
them incorrectly the most confusing part
about trading Candlestick patterns is
figuring out which ones actually work
since there are a lot of them but here's
the truth 99% of these patterns don't
actually work and I know this because
I've tested all of them throughout my
trading career however I found that a
handful of them worked extremely well
and to this day have made me a lot of
profit in this video I'll reveal the top
six Candlestick patterns proven to work
as well as everything you need to know
about them as a bonus I'll also reveal
how to combine these patterns with price
action to find High win rate trade
entries and by the way I've created a
free guide which compiles all the high
win rate patterns into one document
inside I show real trade examples of
these patterns along with some tips and
tricks to increase their win rate you
can use this guide as a reference
whenever you're Trading so if you want
access to it you can pick it up inside
my free telegram Community Link is in
the description now let's begin the
video first what are candlesticks
candlesticks are a simple way to look at
Price history each Candlestick
represents a price move of an asset for
a particular period of time for example
if you're on the 1hour time frame each
candle represents the price history for
1 hour if you're on the daily time frame
then each candle represents price
history for one day
a common question I hear from beginner
Traders is why shouldn't we just use
LINE charts to look at Price wouldn't it
be simpler the answer is that
Candlestick charts actually give us
significantly more information about the
market compared to a line chart and let
me show you an example so let's use this
Euro doll pair as an example on the left
we have the line chart and on the right
we're using the Candlestick chart as you
can see both charts move in a similar
shape which is expected since they both
display the price however notice that
the line chart only shows us one piece
of information the closing price for
each period in contrast the Candlestick
chart provides four pieces of
information for the same time period
first there's the open which is the
opening price for that period next is
the high which shows the highest price
reached within that period then there's
the low which is the lowest price
reached during that period and finally
the close which is the closing price if
you were to use only the line chart the
closing price would be the only
information you'd get to see this more
clearly here's a comparison between a
line chart and a Candlestick chart
forming as you can see the line chart
only displays the closing price for each
period while the Candlestick chart shows
more information about price movements
during the same period so what makes
these extra information so
important as Traders these these
information gives us a better
understanding of the market allowing us
to make more informed decisions for
example let's say that price hits a
support level and bounces if we're only
using line charts the only information
we know is that the price dropped to
this point and then bounced off however
when we switch to a Candlestick chart it
tells a different story The Candlestick
chart shows that at one point the price
actually dipped below the support level
as indicated by the long Wick before
moving back up and eventually closing at
the key level if we were using only a
line chart we wouldn't know this
information details like these are
crucial for Price action Traders because
they can hint at where the price might
go next there are two types of
candlesticks green candles and red
candles a green Candlestick forms when
the candle closes above its opening
price showing that buyers were stronger
than sellers similarly a red Candlestick
forms when the closing price is below
the opening price showing that sellers
were stronger than
buyers a single Candlestick consists of
two parts the wick also called the
shadows and the body the end of the
upper Wick shows the highest price
reached during that period while the end
of the lower Wick shows the lowest price
reached during that period for the
candle's body however things are a bit
different on a green candle the bottom
of the body shows the opening price for
that period and the top shows the
closing price for a red candle it's the
the opposite the top shows the opening
price and the bottom shows the closing
price when we look at a chart we'll
notice that candlesticks come in various
shapes some have larger bodies others
have longer Wicks on one side and some
have small bodies with short Wicks each
of these shapes gives us unique
information about price movements and
understanding them is essential for
Price action traders to analyze the
market more
accurately the first type is candles
with big versus small bodies the body of
a candle can reveal a lot about the
strength or weakness of buyers and
sellers for example let's look at a
green candle with a big body this type
of candle shows that buyers were much
more dominant this is because price
opened at a lower level but because the
buying pressure was so high and sellers
were weaker buyers were able to push the
price up significantly without much
resistance from sellers this is why the
candle closes in this shape
similarly a red candle with a big body
shows that sellers were much more
dominant the price opened at a higher
level but since sellers were stronger
they managed to push it down
significantly with Little Resistance
moving the price sharply downwards
before the candle
closes a candle with a small body tells
a different story a green candle with a
small body shows that although buyers
were in control they weren't very
dominant as sellers also put up a lot of
resistance the price opened lower and
buyers tried to pushing it up but since
sellers were almost as strong the price
didn't move much and ended near the
opening price this is why the candle has
a small body similarly a red candle with
a small body shows that sellers were in
control but not
dominant the price opened at a point
above and sellers pushed it down however
due to either a lack of selling pressure
or strong resistance from buyers they
couldn't push the price down
significantly which is why the candle
closes in this
shape second type is candles with large
Wicks the size of a candle's Wick also
gives us valuable information about
price
action for example a candle with a long
wick on the bottom side indicates
significant buying pressure this is
because for a wick to be long on the
bottom the price must have moved down
significantly at one point however
before the candle closed buyers were
strong enough to push the price back up
considerably this is why a long Wick
below indicates strong buying pressure
for the complete opposite a candle with
a long wick on the upper side indicates
strong selling pressure this is because
for the wick to be long on the upper
side the price must have moved up
significantly at one point reaching a
high level however before the candle
closed sellers managed to reject this
upward move and push the price back down
considerably this is why a long upper
Wick indicates strong selling pressure
the third type is candles with a small
body and equal Wix if a candle has a
small body and equal Wix it indicates
that neither buyers nor sellers are in
strong control this is because both
buyers and sellers tried to push the
price up and down during this period but
neither side was significantly dominant
so the candle closed near its opening
price in this example buyers had a
slight Advantage as the candle closes
green however their strength is still
nearly equal to the
sellers understanding the concepts of
body and Wix is essential as we begin
learning about basic Candlestick
patterns so keep them in mind as we move
forward now I'm going to show you my top
six Candlestick patterns that I found to
be the most
effective number one is the engulfing
pattern an engulfing pattern is a
Candlestick pattern made up of two
candles a smaller first candle followed
by a larger candle of the opposite color
the key point is that the body of the
second candle needs to fully cover the
body of the first
candle there are two types of engulfing
patterns bullish engulfing pattern which
when the smaller candle is red and the
larger candle is green and bearish
engulfing pattern which when the smaller
candle is green and the larger candle is
red when you see an engulfing pattern on
a price chart it could signal a
potential Trend reversal for example if
the price is in a downtrend and a
bullish engulfing pattern forms it may
signal an upward reversal meaning the
price could go up
this is because the pattern shows that
buyers have grown stronger as seen by
the large green candle pushing the price
higher than the previous red candle
indicating a possible reversal the
bigger the second candle the greater the
chance of a price reversal to trade this
pattern we should confirm other factors
to support our bias which we'll discuss
later however if you see a valid bullish
engulfing pattern form you can enter a
buy position at the close of the large
candle with your stop loss set at the
bottom Wick of the green
candle the same applies to bearish
engulfing patterns when a bearish
engulfing pattern forms it could signal
a possible downward reversal as the
large red candle indicates that sellers
have gained strength over buyers if you
spot a bearish engulfing pattern you can
enter a sell position at the candle's
close with your stoploss set at the top
Wick of the red
candle pattern number two is the pin bar
a pin bar is a Candlestick pattern made
up of just one candle characterized by a
large wick on one side and a small body
there are two types of pin bar patterns
a bullish pin bar is when the candle is
green with a longer wick on the bottom
and a bearish pin bar which is when the
candle is red with a longer wick on the
top when you see a pin bar candle
forming in on a chart it means that
sellers initially took control pushing
the price down to a low point but then
buyers stepped in rejected that move and
pushed the price back up before the
candle closed this shows that while both
sides were active buyers ultimately came
out stronger some Traders might enter a
buy position as soon as they see a
bullish pin bar but I prefer to wait for
another green candle to form confirming
the trend once the trend is confirmed
you can take a buy position after the
candle closes and place a stop loss at
the bottom of the pin Bar's wig
the same approach applies to bearish pin
bars if you see one forming it means
that buyers initially took control and
pushed the price up but sellers
ultimately rejected this move and drove
the price back down before the candle
closed you could wait for an additional
red candle to form for extra
confirmation then you can look for a
sell opportunity with the stop loss
placed at the top of the pin Bar's
Wick moving on to pattern number three
three which is the three bar
continuation pattern this pattern
consists of three consecutive candles
that need to form in sequence the first
candle should have a large body and be
bigger than the average candle the
second candle is a smaller opposite
colored candle that ideally shouldn't be
more than half the size of the first
candle's body the third candle should be
another large candle that closes higher
than the second candle's close there are
two types of three bar continuation
patterns a bullet bullish pattern where
the first and third candles are large
green candles with a small red candle in
the middle and a bearish pattern where
the first and third candles are large
red candles with a small green candle in
the middle whenever you see this type of
pattern on a chart it could indicate a
possible continuation of the current
trend for example if the price is in an
uptrend and a bullish three bar
continuation pattern forms it suggests
the price may continue Rising this can
be a good opportunity to enter a long
position if you miss the initial uptrend
with a stop loss at the bottom Wick of
the second
candle it's the opposite for bearish
three bar continuation patterns When You
See It forming in the middle of a
downtrend it may suggest that the
downtrend will continue in this case you
could enter a sell position at the close
of the third candle with a stop loss at
the top Wick of the second
candle moving on to pattern number four
which is the three bar reversal pattern
this pattern consists of a sequence of
three candles the first candle is large
with a nearly full body the second
candle is smaller has the same color as
the first and has a small body the third
candle is a large full-bodied candle of
the opposite color to the first two the
size of the third candle's body affects
the success rate of this pattern if the
third candle's body is equal to or
larger than the first candle it suggests
a higher success rate and is considered
a strong entry signal if the third
candle is smaller than the first this
suggests a lower chance of success and
is considered a weaker entry signal
there are two types of three bar
reversal patterns the bullish three bar
reversal where the first two candles are
red and the third is green and the
bearish three bar reversal where the
first two candles are green and the
third is red as the name suggests
whenever you see this type of pattern on
a chart it signals a possible reversal
of the existing trend for example during
a downtrend if you see a bullish three
bar reversal pattern forming it signals
that the trend might reverse upward to
trade this you can enter a buy position
at the closing price of the third candle
and place your stop loss at the lows of
the second
candle in the case of a bearish three
bar reversal pattern it's the opposite
during an uptrend if this pattern
appears it it signals that the trend May
reverse downward in this case you can
enter a short position at the closing
price of the third candle and stop loss
placed at the highs of the second
candle moving on to pattern number five
which is breakout candles this is a type
of Candlestick pattern where we have
multiple small candles with small bodies
forming followed by a large-bodied
candle this pattern shows that the price
was stagnant for a while with no clear
Direction until one side buyers in this
example push the price significantly
upward in this setup the series of small
candles is called consolidation candles
and the large candle is known as the
breakout candle for this to be a valid
pattern there need to be at least three
consolidation candles however the more
consolidation Candles there are the
higher the chance of a successful
breakout there are two types of breakout
patterns a bullish breakout pattern
where the breakout candle is green and a
bearish breakout pattern where the
breakout candle is red note that for
both bullish and bearish patterns the
color of the consolidation candles is
unimportant what matters is that they're
small in size whenever you see this set
up on a chart you'll usually observe a
continuation in the direction of the
breakout candle let's look at an example
here the price formed a series of small
candles before a large green candle
appeared forming a bullish breakout
pattern this signals that the trend will
likely continue
upward to trade this setup you can enter
a buy position at the close of the
breakout candle with a stoploss placed
at the opening price of the breakout
candle the same principle applies to
short entries for instance if you see
multiple small candles forming as the
price moves sideways followed by a large
red candle this would count as a bearish
breakout pattern you can open a short
position at the close of the breakout
candle with a stoploss placed at the
opening price of the breakout
candle pattern number six is shrinking
candles this is a Candlestick pattern
that consists of at least three
consecutive candles of the same color
each getting smaller followed by a large
candle of the opposite
color this pattern suggests that the
trend is gradually weakening as
indicated by the shrinking candles then
a large candle appears confirming the
reversal the size of the four candle
affects the likelihood of a successful
reversal larger candles show stronger
momentum increasing the probability of a
reversal I recommend looking for a
pattern where the fourth candle closes
above the second candle there are two
types of shrinking candles a bullish
shrinking candle pattern where the three
shrinking candles are red and the fourth
candle is green and a bearish shrinking
candle pattern where the three shrinking
candles are green and the fourth candle
is red whenever you see this type of
pattern on a chart it signals a possible
reversal of the current trend for
example if the price is in a downtrend
and you spot three consecutive red
candles each smaller than the last this
signals that the previous downtrend is
losing momentum after that a large green
candle forms showing that buyers are now
more dominant and signaling a potential
reversal to the upside if you see this
setup on a chart you can enter a long
position at the close of the green
candle with a stop loss at the below of
the previous
candle the same principle applies to
bearish shrinking candles for instance
if the price is in an uptrend and you
notice three green candles getting
progressively smaller this shows that
the uptrend is weakening then a large
red candle forms ideally closing below
the second candle indicating that
sellers are now in control and
confirming a reversal to the downside in
this case you can enter a short position
at the close of the red candle with a
stop loss at the high of the previous
candle so those are the six Candlestick
patterns that I've found to work now
keep in mind when traded on their own
these patterns may not always be as
effective however if you combine them
with other forms of analysis like key
levels they can become much more
powerful so now I'm going to introduce
an advanced price action strategy that
you can use alongside these patterns
this is the same strategy I use to
achieve strong returns to start you'll
want to prioritize higher time frames
any time frame at or above the 1hour
chart is better this is because
Candlestick patterns are generally much
less effective on Lower time frames so
the first step of the strategy is to
identify a key level on a chart there
are many types of key levels like
support and resistance Dynamic key
levels trend lines Fibonacci levels and
more I won't discuss all of them in this
video because it would take too long but
to keep things simple for this tutorial
we can start by finding support and
resistance levels or trend lines here's
an example in this chart we can see the
price has formed a downtrend and
reversed twice at a specific area making
it a level of support now that we've
identified our key level the next step
is to wait for the price to interact
with it once again at this third
retracement we're expecting the price to
bounce once more but we'll need extra
confirmation from a Candlestick pattern
that supports our uptrend bias in this
example we see a large red candle
followed by a smaller red candle and
then a large green candle which closes
above the body of the first candle if
you remember from the patterns we've
learned this matches the characteristics
of a bullish three bar reversal pattern
suggesting that the price May reverse to
the upside you can enter a buy position
at the high of the third candle place a
stop loss at the low of the second
candle and set a take-profit Target at
twice the size of the stock loss as you
can see after our entry the price moved
up hitting our take-profit
Target here's another example in this
chart we see that the price is in a
downtrend and it has formed a support-
turned resistance level this happens
because the price initially formed a
support level as price rejected it once
but then price broke below it and is now
approaching it again from the bottom
making this an area of resistance
however we also see that the price has
made two lower high points creating a
strong trend line this area where the
trend line and resistance level
intersect is called a Confluence level
an area where multiple key levels meet
price is more likely to reverse at a
Confluence level now we wait for the
price to reach this Confluence level
once it does we anticipate a reversal
but we still need
confirmation looking closely we see
three green candles each getting smaller
in size followed by a large red candle
this pattern shows that as the price
approached our Confluence level buying
pressure was fading giving sellers the
opportunity to step in this is the
characteristic of a shrinking candle
pattern which strengthens our
expectation that the price will reverse
downward from this level this setup
provides a good opportunity to enter
short then you can place a stop loss
above the high of the previous candle
and set a take-profit at twice the size
of the stop-loss as you can see the
price moved down and reached our profit
Target shortly after entry now if you've
watched the tutorial this far I assume
you're one of the few people who are
truly serious about learning how to
trade so if you feel like you got value
from this video and want to learn even
more I've created a free guide that
compiles all the high win rate
Candlestick patterns from this video
into one file which you can use as a
quick reference in case you need a
refresher inside you'll find more
in-depth explanations and trade examples
for each pattern along with three more
High win rate strategies that I didn't
show in this video so if you'd like
access to the guide you can pick it up
in my free telegram Community which I've
Linked In the description just go to the
files section and the guide will be
there inside you'll also get access to
my free market analysis on Forex and
crypto which I will be posting regularly
so if you're serious about leveling up
your trading skills join the free
community I'll see you there